now this is getting serious michael
smith you see these headlines
uh from around the nfl mike florio says
the texans claim they're holding firm on
deshaun watson
and that's the thing texans
standing firm and and there are a lot of
things that
there are a lot of questions that need
to be asked here one
we say the texans are standing firm
who's representing the texans is it
their new
rookie general manager nick casario
is it the guy who the general manager in
the shadows
that would be jack easterby uh is it
uh tommyboy
i love that nickname i love that
nickname so much i love the movie and
the nickname
uh cal mcnair that's what some people
derisively call him
uh tommy boy um so i wonder
or is it new coach david cully is it a
combination of all these people
desean watson clearly has gone to the
texans and has requested a trade
uh privately and publicly they say
they're not
trading desean watson they said it
publicly we saw that at david culley's
press conference mike
and then privately according to sources
people are calling the texans
and they're being they're getting the
heisman no
we are not interested in trading watson
now i think this is a mistake
i wonder why they are flexing
on this especially at this time of year
it's not going to change you need to
listen to grown folks
because grown folks usually have a
process most of the time i'm not saying
all the time but most of the time grown
folks have a process
so if they got a an issue with you
and they feel like it's a legitimate
issue
that thing is not usually resolved with
like some kind of sweet
gloss over let's sit down have some tea
some sweet tea
and let's talk about this deshaun
watson's a grown man
it's february the texans have no draft
picks
they need to make some moves they got a
rookie general manager and a rookie head
coach
and they got a veteran quarterback more
veteran than they are who knows what he
wants to do he wants out
and for them to continue to say they're
not going to let them out
i think it's a disaster and a huge
mistake
um yeah if it's if it's leverage
and there are conversations
being had or calls being placed the
offers being extended
and this is sort of like it and we'll
get to them momentarily because i think
there's a connection sort of like the
eagles not liking what they're hearing
so far
if this is the texas not liking what
they're hearing and just maintaining a
public posture that we're not doing this
which is code for come correct or don't
come at all
that's one thing but i don't think it's
football reasons because you're talking
about football reasons
honestly man i think this is this is uh
this is the ghost of bob mcnair this is
this is not letting the inmate run the
prison
i think it's just i think that's it i
think i think they are doing this to
prove a point
and like i said my prediction is that
they go cut off their nose to spike
their face
they're going to get into a stare down
they're getting into into a
a a mexican standoff
with desean watson and just decide okay
you're not going to play we'll see we'll
see okay you under contract
okay we'll play hard but they want to
play hardball
when honestly the solution is is really
really simple
it's really simple and all it takes is
just like setting pride aside
and thinking practically he's asked for
a trade
let him seek it go okay cool you got
permission
go seek a trade we're not making you any
promises
we're not telling you that you're going
to have a trade that you're bringing
back to us that satisfies what we think
is proper value proper return on an
asset such as yourself desean
but you have our permission to go try so
hey you know what we messed up
we got it by the way it's a
miscommunication here what does that
mean
what does that mean okay so if he goes
and he says um
he has permission to seek a trade that
means if he goes to the jets
david mulligans will the jets broker and
trade
bring us something bring us back an
offer we can't refuse david
okay put it put the agent to work put
the put his super agent he has a super
agent
put david mulligan to work and it's like
this it's like okay hey man we messed up
we got our wires crossed okay are we
waiting
on our timer we do that though and maybe
maybe sean maybe we implied
the wrong thing no maybe but okay
listen we're trying we're trying to do
better we're trying to do better sean
that's a good question because you
wasted your time
investigating coaches and general
managers
because you got the impression that
you're going to have a real seat at the
table
a real voice when it came to the future
of this franchise to the direction of
this organization
now maybe maybe you infer that maybe we
implied it either way there was
miscommunication
okay we went we hired nick cesario you
found out in mexico you're upset i got
it you don't think you were a true
partner in this process
let's rectify that we'll be a partner in
this process from this moment on okay
you have our permission to go in secret
trade we make you no promises
on whether or not we will actually trade
you but since you want to out of dodge
so bad
it says you want away from this
organization so bad we're not going to
just ignore you we're not going to treat
you like a child who's throwing a temper
tantrum we're actually going to listen
to you we're going to take you seriously
allow you and your agent to go and go to
any any team you want to go to you have
no trade clause for crime out loud
anything you want to go to
figure out a trade package bring it back
to us we'll go from there
if you don't bring us back something
that we like you'll be here
just so we're clear we're not giving you
away
but we'll at least explore it to see if
there actually
is a trade out there that makes us
better
as a football team far fetched there
that may seem because i personally
don't believe that there's a trade that
makes us better than having you on the
team to sean that's how highly we think
of you
we don't think there's a trade that
makes us better that happens
but if you go get about if you look at
us a herschel walker trade
we'll gladly listen but we're making no
promises how about that let's work
together on this
and the way that we didn't work on it
before all right peace bro appreciate
you
talk to you later that's the
conversation but a trade that makes them
better
a trade that makes them better is a tr
is any trade
because my talent
my talent will nest will not necessarily
be realized
here because i don't want to be here so
if i don't want to be here no matter how
talented i
am it doesn't matter
i don't like i don't i don't respect you
i don't like the way i don't
trust you i guess so you're not gonna
get it
and you know we're not gonna you have
every reason to be frustrated
you have every reason to be to feel that
way and i get why you feel that way
and while i think um nick casario
and david cully i think if you give them
a chance to sean i think if you give
them a chance
we actually have a chance to turn this
thing around i know our track record to
this point
may not support that so i get where your
frustrations lie and i get that it's
really hard
watching your contemporaries watching
your peers in the playoffs
while you have this historic season on a
4-12 team
i get it i'm as frustrated as you are
we're as frustrated as you are this is
unacceptable this is not what we want
however i know you're saying that
or you're intimating that any trade is
better
because you won't be here okay well if
that's the route you choose to go that's
fine you do what you have to do
but in that case we believe that there's
value
attached to you that even in your
absence
is worth holding on to you until
the right trade comes along so hopefully
it doesn't come to that deshaun we
let's we'd love to talk this out and
figure out a way to rectify this
situation
but if this ship has sailed then
i mean i listen i'm not trying to
disrespect you but you're under contract
and we are the captain of this ship and
so
we're going to decide how this is going
to proceed but we want to involve you in
this process
as best we can and so
go out find a trade you're looking for
with the team that you want to play for
and we'll go from there that's the best
we can you know what he'll say
i mean bro that's the best we could do
that that's that's pretty good
uh calming that's a pretty good
composite acting mcnair pretty good
actor
scenario and you know what you know what
uh
they would never know john watson they
would never say anything like that
what would you say what did you say
he would say is that what you think
you want to pull the rock it doesn't
matter what you think
it doesn't matter what you think
i'm out i'm out i'm out of are you not
going to see you
you're not going to see your boy in
training camp i'm not going to be there
i'm not going to help make david
culley's transition
i hear you to his head coach on your job
i'm not going to make that smooth
i hear you not your cereal i'm not going
to make it but
i hear you i'm out you can't trade
yourself you can't trade yourself
and i can make sure myself never know
trade clause so we can make sure myself
does it without
permission you could withhold your
services
you have that right yes and we have the
right to find you we don't want to do
that
we have the right to come back and for
your money we don't want to do that and
i'm not trying to test your gangster
i have no doubt that you're willing to
go to take it this far i have no doubt
about it
so let's move forward amicably what's
the solution
we don't want to trade you you don't
want to be here
there's only one way out of this and
that's to find a trade that we can't
refuse
go for it you have our permission you
know what mike
i think those trades are i think that
trade is out there i mean based on
i don't want to go too crazy because
everybody because i'm not sure
that matthew stafford uh like the rams
lions trade is the market i think it's a
market it
it had so many things in place that were
just perfect for both sides
i'm not sure we can use that as a
baseline to determine
what's going to happen going forward
with every quarterback involving
every trade involving a pro bowl
quarterback i don't think that's
i don't think that's sustainable but
with deshaun watson
i think his market is very strong and
it's very it's rare that you're going to
have teams that
he's interested in going to in prime
draft position
for the texans you can't get better
short of the number one pick they're not
gonna that's not gonna happen i don't
think he wants to go to jacksonville
jacksonville is probably
not willing to trade the number i
wouldn't i would oh by the way we're not
dealing with
jacksonville anyway crosstalk whatever
list you have to sean we're not dealing
with jacksonville so
you know anybody else yeah we're not
dealing with jacksonville but you're
talking about miami and the jets
and number two and number three and then
miami has
that's really our asset that the
previous general manager screwed up
and allowed them to have that i could
just see that that's a good fit for
deshaun watson it's a good fit for
the texans you get great value and there
are quarterbacks there
at least at least two
yeah that are worthy of your election
yeah let's figure it out let's figure it
out together okay i don't want to play
the texans anymore
that was fun i know i took that off i
want it it's awful
i i was that was it was it was fun to
get into character and
role play but i want to move on to
another quarterback now
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
three to five pm eastern time on peacock
appreciate you